La limite de 18 minutes est absolument brutale,
je vais donc attaquer mon sujet tout de suite, sans tourner autour du pot,
aussitôt que j'arriverai à faire marcher ce truc.
Voilà. Je vais parler de cinq choses différentes.
Je vais parler des raisons pour lesquelles il est souhaitable de vaincre le vieillissement.
Je vais parler des raisons pour lesquelles il faut qu'on se remue,
et qu'on se mette vraiment à en parler un peu plus qu'on ne le fait actuellement.
Je parlerai aussi de la faisabilité, bien entendu.
Je vais parler des raisons pour lesquelles nous sommes si fatalistes
lorsqu'il s'agit d'agir contre le vieillissement.
Et puis je passerai peut-être à la deuxième moitié de l'exposé
à parler de, voyez-vous, comment nous pourrions être capable de prouver que l'on a tort d'être fataliste,
c'est à dire - en faisant réellement quelque chose pour y remédier.
Je vais procéder en deux étapes.
La première chose dont je vais parler, c'est
comment passer d'une extension de vie relativement modeste --
disons 30 ans, appliquée à des gens
qui sont déjà d'âge moyen quand on commence --
jusqu'au point où l'on peut vraiment parler de vaincre le vieillissement.
C'est à dire, une élimination du rapport entre
votre âge et la probabilité que vous avez de mourir l'année prochaine --
ou même de tomber malade.
Et bien sûr, la dernière chose dont je vais parler
est comment arriver à ce point intermédiaire,
ce point de, peut-être, 30 ans d'extension de vie.
Donc, je vais commencer en expliquant pourquoi nous devrions le faire.
Maintenant je veux poser une question.
Levez la main: qui parmi vous est en faveur de la malaria?
C'était facile. OK.
OK. Levez la main, qui parmi le public
ne sait pas si la malaria est une bonne ou une mauvaise chose?
Bon. Nous pensons tous que la malaria est une mauvaise chose.
C'est une très bonne nouvelle, parce que c'est justement la réponse à laquelle je m'attendais.
Ce qu'il y a, c'est que j'aimerais vous suggérer
que la principale raison pour laquelle nous pensons que la malaria est une mauvaise chose
est à cause d'une caractéristique de la malaria qu'elle a en commun avec le vieillissement.
Et voici cette caractéristique.
la seule véritable différence est que le vieillissement tue considérablement plus de monde que la malaria.
Maintenant, surtout en Grande Bretagne, j'aime devant un public
faire une comparaison avec la chasse au renard,
qui est quelque chose qui a été interdit après une longue lutte,
par le gouvernement il y a seulement quelques mois.
Je veux dire, je sais bien que j'ai ici un public qui m'est bien disposé
mais, comme nous le savons, beaucoup de gens ne sont pas tout à fait persuadés par cette logique.
Et celle-ci est, en fait, plutôt une bonne comparaison, me semble-t-il.
Vous savez, beaucoup de gens ont dit, "Bon, vous savez,
les citadins n'on pas le droit de dire à nous, des gens de la campagne, comment nous devrions nous occuper.
C' est un aspect traditionnel de notre mode de vie,
et l'on devrait nous permettre de le poursuivre.
C'est écologique; cela freine l'explosion démographique des renards."
Mais finalement, le gouvernement l'a emporté,
parce que la majorité du public britannique,
et certainement la majorité des parlementaires,
a conclu qu'il sagissait là vraiment de quelque chose
qu'une société civilisée ne peut se permettre de tolérer.
Et moi, je pense que le vieillissement humain partage
toutes ces caractéristiques en abondance.
Qu'est que c'est que les gens ne comprennent pas dans tout cela?
Il ne s'agit pas seulement de la vie, bien sûr --
(Rires)
il s'agit d'une vie saine, vous savez --
faiblir, devenir misérable et dépendant n'est pas amusant,
que mourir le soit ou pas.
Alors vraiment, c'est comme ça que je voudrais le décrire.
C'est une transe mondiale.
voici le genre d'excuses incroyables
que les gens donnent pour le vieillissement.
Et, je veux dire, d'accord, je ne prétends pas
que ces excuses sont tout à fait sans valeur.
Il y a là quelques bons points.
Des choses auxquelles nous devrions penser, planifier
pour que rien ne soit catastrophique, enfin pour minimiser
la turbulence qui surviendra lorsque nous arriverons à comprendre comment remédier au vieillissement.
Mais ce sont là des questions tout à fait folles, lorsque vous pensez
à garder un sens des proportions.
Vous savez, ce sont des arguments, des choses à propos desquelles
il serait légitime de s'inquiéter.
Mais la vraie question est, sont-ils aussi dangereux --
ces risques de remédier au vieillissement --
qu'ils dépassent les inconvénients de faire le contraire,
c'est à dire, de laisser le vieillissement tel qu'il est?
Sont ils si mauvais qu'ils dépassent
le fait de condamner 100.000 personnes par jour à une mort prématurée évitable.
Vous savez, si vous n'avez pas un argument qui pèse aussi fort que cela,
alors, je dis ne gaspillez pas mon temps.
(Rires)
Bon, il y a un argument
que certains considèrent comme vraiment très fort et le voici.
Les gens s'inquiètent de la surpopulation, ils disent,
"Bon, si nous vainquons le vieillissement, presque personne ne mourra,
ou du moins le taux de mortalité sera beaucoup plus faible,
seulement dû aux gens qui traversent la rue sans faire attention.
Et par conséquent, nous ne pourrons pas avoir beaucoup d'enfants,
et les enfants sont super importants pour la plupart des gens."
Et c'est vrai.
Et vous savez, beaucoup de gens essayent de brouiller cette question,
et de donner des réponses comme celles-ci.
Je ne suis pas d'accord avec ces réponses. Je pense qu'elles ne marchent pas.
Je pense qu'il est vrai que nous devrons affronter un dilemme à ce sujet.
Nous devrons choisir si nous voulons un taux de natalité faible,
ou un taux de mortalité élevé.
Un taux de mortalité élevé résultera, évidemment, d'un simple rejet de ces thérapies,
pour pouvoir continuer à avoir beaucoup d'enfants.
Et moi je dis que ça va --
la postérité à le droit de faire ce choix.
Ce qui ne va pas, c'est que nous fassions ce choix au nom de la postérité.
Si nous hésitons,
et ne développons pas ces thérapies,
alors nous condamnons toute une cohorte de gens --
qui auraient été assez jeunes et sains
pour bénéficier de ces thérapies mais ne le seront pas,
parce que nous ne les aurons pas mis au point aussi rapidement que nous l'aurions dû
nous priverons ces gens là d'une durée de vie indéterminée,
et je considère cela immoral.
C'est ma réponse à la question de la surpopulation.
Bon. La chose suivante c'est de se demander
pourquoi nous devrions commencer à être un peu plus actifs sur cette question.
Et la réponse fondamentale est que
la transe en faveur du vieillissement n'est pas si bête que ça.
En fait, c'est une façon censée d'affronter l'inéluctabilité du vieillissement.
Vieillir c'est horrible, mais c'est inévitable, alors vous savez,
nous devons trouver une manière de ne pas y penser,
et il est raisonnable de faire quoi que ce soit pour réussir.
Comme, par exemple, inventer ces raisons ridicules
selon lesquelles vieillir serait en fait quelque chose de bon.
Mais bien sûr, cela ne marche que lorsque vous avez les deux composants.
Et dès que le caractère inévitable devient un peu moins évident,
et que nous approchons de la possibilité d'en faire quelque chose,
cette attitude fait partie du problème.
Cette transe en faveur du vieillissement c'est ce qui nous empêche de nous remuer sur ces questions.
Et c'est pour ça que nous devons vraiment en parler beaucoup --
je dirais même évangéliser --
de façon à capter l'attention des gens, de faire qu'ils se rendent compte
qu'ils sont dans une transe à cet égard.
Donc, c'est tout ce que je dirai de cela.
Je vais parler maintenant de la faisabilité.
Et la raison fondamentale, je pense, pour laquelle nous croyons que vieillir est inévitable
se résume dans une définition du vieillissement que je donne ici.
Une définition très simple.
Le vieillissement est un effet secondaire d'être en vie,
c'est à dire, le métabolisme.
Cette affirmation n'est pas tout à fait tautologique;
c'est une affirmation raisonnable.
Vieillir est un processus qui arrive aux objets inanimés comme les voitures,
et qui nous arrive à nous aussi,
malgré le fait que nous avons beaucoup de méchanismes d'auto-réparation plutôt futés,
parce que ces méchanismes sont imparfaits.
Alors, le métabolisme, qui se définit comme
essentiellement tout ce qui nous maintient en vie d'une journée à l'autre,
a des effets secondaires.
Ces effets secondaires s'accumulent et finissent par provoquer des pathologies.
C'est une excellente définition. Alors, nous pouvons dire cela ainsi:
nous pouvons dire, vous savez, qu'il y a cet enchaînement d'évenements.
Et en fait il y a deux approches,
selon la plupart des gens, en ce qui concerne le report du vieillissement
C'est ce que j'appelle l'approche de la gérontologie et l'approche de la gériatrie.
Le gériatre va intervenir tard
quand la pathologie devient évidente,
et le gériatre va essayer de retenir l'écoulement du temps,
et d'empêcher que l'accumulation des effets secondaires
cause des pathologies aussi rapidement que prévu.
Bien sûr c'est une stratégie à très court terme, c'est une bataille perdue d'avance,
parce que les choses qui causent la pathologie
deviennent de plus en plus abondantes au fur et à mesure que le temps passe.
L'approche de la gérontologie apparait beaucoup plus prometteuse d'abord,
parce que, vous savez, mieux vaut prévenir que guérir.
Mais malheureusement, ce qu'il y a, c'est que nous ne comprenons pas très bien le métabolisme.
En réalité, nous avons une compréhension de la façon dont les organismes fonctionnent qui fait pitié par sa carence --
même pour ce qui est des cellules, on n'est vraiment pas encore très forts.
On a découvert des choses comme, par exemple,
l'interférence ARN, il y a seulement quelques années,
et celle-ci est vraiment un élément fondamental du fonctionnement des cellules.
Au fond, la gérontologie est une très bonne approche finalement,
mais ce n'est pas une approche dont l'heure est venue
quand nous parlons d'intervention.
Alors, que faire?
Je veux dire, c'est une belle logique, cela semble fort convaincant,
assez solide, n'est-ce pas?
Mais cela ne l'est pas.
Avant que je vous explique pourquoi, je vais aborder un petit peu
ce que j'appelle la deuxième étape.
Supposons, comme j'ai dit, que nous acquérons --
disons, aujourd'hui --
la capacité de donner 30 ans supplémentaires de vie en bonne santé
à des gens qui sont déjà d'âge moyen, disons 55 ans.
Je vais appeler cela rajeunissement humain robuste. OK.
Qu'est cela voudra dire en réalité
pour ce qui concerne l'espérance de vie de gens d'âges variés aujourd'hui
ou plutôt pour ces gens d'âge variés au moment où ces thérapies --
arriveront?
Pour répondre à cette question -- il se peut que vous pensiez que c'est simple,
Mais ce n'est pas simple.
Nous ne pouvons pas juste dire, "Eh bien, s'ils sont assez jeunes pour bénéficier de ces thérapies
alors ils auront 30 ans supplémentaires de vie."
C'est la mauvaise réponse.
Et la raison pour laquelle c'est la mauvaise réponse, c'est suite au progrès.
En fait, il existe deux sortes de progrès technologiques,
concernant ceci.
Il y a des percées majeures, fondamentales,
et il y a des améliorations progressives de ces percées.
Il se trouve qu'il y a beaucoup de différence entre les deux
en ce qui concerne la possibilité de prévoir des délais.
Percées fondamentales:
très difficile de prédire le temps qu'il faudra
pour avoir une percée fondamentale.
C'était il y a très longtemps que les êtres humains se sont dit que ce serait amusant de voler,
et il a fallu attendre 1903 pour réellement découvrir comment le faire.
Mais après cela les choses se sont déroulées d'une façon plutôt constante et régulière
Je pense que c'est raisonnable de dire que c'est comme ça que les choses sont arrivées
en ce qui concerne les progrès dans la domaine du vol à moteur.
Nous pouvons imaginer, en fait, que chacune des améliorations est plus ou moins
inimaginable pour l'inventeur de la précédente, si vous voulez.
Les avancées progressives accumulées constituent quelque chose
qui ne resemble plus à une simple amélioration.
C'est la sorte de chose qui se produit après une percée fondamentale.
Et vous voyez cela dans toutes sortes de technologies.
Les ordinateurs: vous pouvez voir une ligne du temps plus ou moins analogue,
qui a lieu évidemment un peu plus tard.
Vous pouvez considérer les soins médicaux. Je veux dire l'hygiène, les vaccins, les antibiotiques --
vous savez - c'est la même sorte de ligne du temps.
Donc, je pense que ce que je viens d'appeler la deuxième étape il y a un moment,
ce n'est pas en fait une étape.
En réalité, les gens qui sont assez jeunes
pour bénéficier de ces premières thérapies
qui donnent cette quantité modérée de rallongement de la vie,
quoique ces gens-là sont déjà d'âge moyen lorsque les thérapies arrivent,
vont se trouver à une sorte de moment charnière.
Ils vont pour la plupart vivre assez longtemps pour recevoir des traitements améliorés
qui leur donneront encore 30, ou peut-être 50 ans.
autrement dit, ils vont avoir un train d'avance.
Les thérapies vont s'améliorer plus rapidemment
que la vitesse à laquelle les imperfections restantes des thérapies nous rattrapent.
Il est très important pour moi de vous faire comprendre ce point.
Parce que, vous savez, la plupart des gens, quand ils entendent
que je prévois que beaucoup de gens vivant aujourd'hui vont atteindre 1.000 ans ou plus,
ils pensent que je dis que nous allons inventer des thérapies d'ici quelques décennies
qui éliminent si profondément le vieillissement
que ces thérapies nous permettront de vivre 1.000 ans ou plus.
Ce n'est pas du tout ça que je dis.
Je dis que la vitesse à laquelle ces thérapies vont s'améliorer
sera suffisante.
Elles ne seront jamais parfaites, mais nous pourrons remédier aux choses
dont les gens qui ont 200 ans meurent avant que nous ayons des gens qui ont 200 ans
et c'est pareil pour les gens qui ont 400 ans et ainsi de suite.
J'ai décidé de donner un nom à ce concept,
et c'est "la vitesse d'échappement de la longévité."
(Rires)
Eh bien, il parait que ça fait passer l'idée.
Donc, ces trajectoires ici sont, essentiellement, la longueur de vie qu'on s'attendrait à voir pour les gens
en ce qui concerne l'espérance de vie qui leur reste,
calculée selon leur état de santé,
pour des âges donnés, au moment où ces thérapies arrivent.
Si vous avez déjà 100 ans, ou même 80 --
et vous êtes typique pour les gens de 80 ans,
on ne pourra probablement pas faire grand chose pour vous avec ces thérapies,
parce que vous approchez de trop près la mort
pour que les toutes premières thérapies expérimentales vous suffisent.
Vous ne pourrez pas les supporter.
Mais si vous n'avez que 50 ans, il y a une chance
que vous pourriez sortir de la descente en piqué et, vous savez --
(Rires)
ensuite tenir bon.
Et commencer à devenir biologiquement plus jeune dans un sens réel,
en ce qui concerne votre jeunesse aussi bien physique que mentale,
et en ce qui concerne votre risque de mort des causes liées à l'âge.
Et évidemment, si vous êtes un peu plus jeune que cela,
alors vous n'allez jamais vraiment
même approcher un état où vous seriez assez fragile pour mourir des causes liées à l'âge.
Alors, je conclus, tout à fait sérieusement, que la première personne qui atteindra 150 ans --
nous ne savons pas quel âge elle a aujourd'hui,
car nous ne savons pas combien de temps il nous faudra
pour avoir ces thérapies de première génération.
Mais quoi que soit cet âge-là,
je soutiens que la première personne qui atteindra 1.000 ans --
sauf catastrophes mondiales bien sûr --
a probablement, en fait, seulement 10 ans de moins que la première personne qui atteindra 150 ans.
Et ça c'est quelque chose.
Bon, je vais passer le reste de mon discours,
mes dernières sept minutes et demie, sur la première étape;
c'est à dire, ce qu'il faut finalement que nous fassions pour avoir cette extension modérée de la vie
qui nous permettra d'atteindre la vitesse d'échappement de la longévité.
Et pour ce faire, il faudra que je parle un peu de souris.
J'ai un autre évènement marquant qui correspond au rajeunissment humain robuste.
Je l'appelle - ce n'est pas très original - le rajeunissement robuste d'une souris.
Et il s'agit de ceci.
Je dis que nous allons prendre une race de souris qui vit longtemps,
ce qui veut dire essentiellement des souris qui vivent environ trois ans, en moyenne.
On ne leur fait rien avant qu'elles aient trois ans.
Et puis on leur fait tout un tas de trucs.
Et avec ces thérapies, nous faisons de sorte qu'elles vivent
en moyenne, jusqu'à cinq ans.
Donc, autrement dit, nous ajoutons deux ans --
nous triplons l'espérance de vie qui leur reste,
en commençant au moment où nous avons commencé les thérapies.
La question qui se pose alors, c'est qu'est ce que cela voudrait dire en ce qui concerne la ligne du temps
jusqu'à ce que nous arrivions à l'évènement marquant dont j'ai parlé auparavant pour les êtres humains?
Ce que nous pouvons maintenant, comme j'ai expliqué,
appeler le rajeunissement humain robuste, ou la vitesse d'échappement de la longévité.
Deuxièmement, qu'est-ce que cela signifie pour la perception du public
en ce qui concerne le temps qu'il nous faudra pour atteindre ces objectifs
à partir du moment où nous avons les souris?
Et troisièmement, quel effet cela aura-t-il
sur le désir des gens de les avoir.
Et il me semble que la première question
est entièrement une question de biologie,
et c'est extrêmement difficile de répondre.
On est obligé de prendre une approche très spéculative,
et beaucoup de mes collègues diraient que nous ne devrions pas spéculer ainsi,
et que nous ne devrions tout simplement rien dire avant que nous en sachions plus.
Je dis que ça, c'est n'importe quoi.
Je dis que nous sommes tout à fait irresponsables si nous nous taisons à ce sujet.
Nous devons exprimer notre meilleur supposition en ce qui concerne la ligne du temps,
afin de donner aux gens un sens de la proportion
pour qu'ils puissent considérer leurs priorités.
Donc, je dis que nous avons une chance sur deux
d'atteindre cet évènement marquant du RHR
le Rajeunissement Humain Robuste, dans les 15 ans après le moment
où nous atteignons le rajeunissement robuste d'une souris.
15 ans à partir de la souris robuste.
La perception du public sera probablement quelque peu mieux que cela.
Le public à tendance à sous estimer combien sont difficiles les choses scientifiques.
Alors probablement ils penseront que cela va arriver dans cinq ans.
Ils auront tort, mais en fait cela ne sera pas si mal que ça.
Et finalement, évidemment, je pense que c'est raisonnable de dire
que le fait que le public a une attitude si ambigüe actuellement envers le vieillissement s'explique en grande partie
par la transe mondiale dont je parlais avant, la stratégie d'adaptation.
Qui appartiendra à l'histoire ancienne à ce moment,
parce que ce ne sera plus possible de croire que le vieillissement est inévitable pour les humains,
puisqu'on l'aura freiné d'une façon si efficace pour les souris.
Alors il est probable que nous aurons finalement un changement très marqué des attitudes,
et évidemment cela a des implications énormes.
Donc, afin de vous expliquer comment nous allons parvenir à avoir ces souris,
je vais rajouter un peu à ma description du vieillissement.
Je vais utiliser ce mot "dégâts"
pour signifier ces choses intermédiaires qui sont causées par le métabolisme,
et qui finalement causent la pathologie.
Parce que la chose primordiale ici
c'est que, quoique les dégâts ne causent la pathologie qu'à long terme,
les dégâts eux-mêmes sont causés de façon continue tout au long de la vie, en commençant avant que nous soyons nés.
Mais ils ne font pas partie du métabolisme eux-mêmes.
Et il se trouve que ceci est utile.
Parce que nous pouvons redessiner notre schéma ainsi.
Nous pouvons dire que, fondamentalement, la différence entre la gérontologie et la gériatrie,
c'est que la gérontologie essaie de freiner la vitesse
à laquelle le métabolisme cause ces dégâts.
Et je vais expliquer exactement ce que sont les dégâts
en termes biologiques concrets dans un instant.
Et les gériatres essaient de retenir l'écoulement du temps
en empêchant que les dégâts ne se convertissent en pathologie.
Et la raison pour laquelle c'est une bataille perdue d'avance
c'est parce que les dégâts continuent de s'accumuler.
Alors, il existe une troisième approche, si on regarde la situation ainsi.
On peut l'appeler l'approche de l'ingénierie,
et je soutiens que l'approche de l'ingénierie est à notre portée.
L'approche de l'ingénierie n'intervient en aucun processus.
Il n'intervient ni dans celui-ci ni dans celui-là.
Et ça c'est bien, parce que cela veut dire que ce n'est pas une bataille perdue d'avance,
et c'est quelque chose dont nous approchons de la possibilité d'y remédier,
parce que cela n'implique pas une amélioration de l'évolution.
L'approche de l'ingénierie dit tout simplement:
"Allons-y - de temps en temps on répare toutes ces sortes variées de dégâts --
pas nécessairement une réparation totale, mais assez importante,
pour que nous tenions le niveau de dégâts en-dessous du seuil
qui doit exister, au-delà duquel ils causent la pathologie."
Nous savons que ce seuil existe,
parce que nous ne souffrons pas de maladies liées au vieillissement avant d'avoir atteint un âge moyen,
quoique les dégâts se soient accumulés depuis avant notre naissance.
Pourquoi dis-je que c'est à notre portée de faire ceci? Et bien, la raison en est la suivante.
Le but de cette diapositive, c'est ce qui se trouve en bas.
Si nous essayons de dire quelles parties du métabolisme sont importantes pour le vieilliessement,
on sera ici toute la nuit, parce que essentiellement tout le métabolisme
est important pour le vieillissement d'une façon ou d'une autre.
Cette liste, c'est juste à titre d'exemple, elle est incomplète.
La liste à droite, elle aussi, est incomplète.
C'est une liste de sortes de pathologies qui sont liées au vieillissement,
et c'est une liste incomplète.
Mais je voudrais soutenir que cette liste au milieu est en fait complète,
il s'agit de la liste des sortes de choses qu'on peut considérer comme dégâts,
des effets secondaires du métabolisme qui finissent par causer la pathologie,
ou qui pourraient causer la pathologie.
Et il n'y en a que sept.
Elles sont des catégories de choses, évidemment, mais il n'y en a que sept.
Perte de cellules, mutations dans les chromosomes, mutations dans les mitochondies et ainsi de suite.
D'abord je voudrais vous donner une explication de pourquoi cette liste est complète.
Bien sûr, on peut donner une explication biologique.
On peut dire, d'accord, de quoi sommes-nous faits?
Nous sommes faits de cellules et de matériau entre les cellules.
Qu'est-ce qui peut accumuler des dégâts?
La réponse c'est dans des molécules d'une grande longévité,
parce que si une molécule d'une courte longévité est endommagée, mais qu'ensuite elle est détruite,
comme, par exemple, lorsque une protéine est détruite par la protéolyse - alors les dégâts sont partis également.
Il faut que ce soient des molécules qui vivent longtemps.
Donc, ces sept choses ont toutes fait l'objet de discussions depuis longtemps en gérontologie
et ça c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle parce que cela veut dire que,
vous savez, nous avons fait beaucoup de chemin ces dernières 20 années,
alors le fait que nous n'avons pas ajouté à cette liste
c'est une assez bonne indication qu'il n'y a rien à ajouter.
Cependant, c'est encore mieux que cela - en fait nous savons comment remédier à toutes ces choses
dans des souris, en principe -- et ce que je veut dire par en principe, c'est que
probablement nous pourrons mettre en oeuvre ces remèdes dans une décennie.
Quelques-uns sont partiellement mis en œuvre déjà - ceux qui se trouvent en haut.
Je n'ai pas le temps de les aborder tous mais
ma conclusion c'est que si nous pouvons trouver des fonds adéquats pour tout cela
alors nous pouvons probablement développer le rajeunissement robuste d'une souris d'ici 10 ans
mais il faut que nous y travaillions de façon sérieuse.
Il faut vraiment qu'on commence à essayer de le faire.
Alors bien sûr il y a des biologistes parmi le public ici
et je veux répondre à quelques-unes des questions que peut-être vous voulez poser.
sommes no
mais au fond il faudrait que vous en lisiez plus,
j'ai publié énormément de choses sur tout cela;
je cite le travail expérimental sur lequel mon optimisme se base,
et il y a pas mal de détails.
Ce sont les détails qui me rendent confiant
pour les lignes de temps plutôt courtes que je prévois ici.
Alors si vous pensez que je me trompe,
alors, mince, il faut bien que vous alliez découvrir pourquoi vous pensez que j'ai tort.
Et bien sûr, la chose principale, c'est que vous ne devez pas avoir confiance dans les gens
qui s'appellent des gérontologues parce que
comme lorsqu'il est question de n'importe quel départ radical dans un champ donné,
vous savez, il faut s'attendre à ce que les gens dans le courant dominant vont faire un peu de résistance
et ne pas le prendre vraiment au sérieux.
Donc, vous voyez, vous devez vraiment étudier la question,
pour comprendre si ce que je dis est vrai.
Et nous allons maintenant terminer avec quelques points.
Une point c'est, vous savez, vous allez entendre un type dans le prochain discours
qui a dit il y a un bout de temps qu'il pouvait séquencer le génome humain en un rien de temps,
et tout le monde a dit: "Et bien, évidemment c'est impossible."
Et vous savez ce qui est arrivé.
Donc, vous savez, ceci arrive.
Nous avons plusieurs stratégies -- il y a le prix de la souris Mathusalem,
qui est essentiellement une façon d'inciter les gens à innover,
et de faire ce que vous pensez qui va marcher,
et vous recevez de l'argent si vous gagnez.
Il y a une proposition de créer un institut.
Ce qui nécessiterait un peu d'argent.
Mais, je veux dire, regardez -- combien de temps il leur faut pour dépenser cela pour la guerre en Iraq?
Pas très longtemps. OK.
(Rires)
Il faut que ce soit philanthropique parce que les bénéfices font s'égarer la biotechnologie,
mais on a, essentiellement, une chance à 90%, je pense, de réussir en ceci.
Et je pense que nous savons comment le faire. Et je vais arrêter là.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Chris Anderson: Aubrey: Je ne sais pas s'il y aura des questions
mais je voulais que les gens aient la possibilité d'en poser.
Public: Puisque vous avez parlé du vieillissement et d'essayer de le vaincre,
pourquoi vous vous faites ressembler à un vieillard?
(Rires)
AG: Parce que je suis un vieillard. En l'occurence, j'ai 158 ans.
(Applaudissements)
Public: Les espèces sur cette planète ont évolué avec des systèmes immunitaires,
pour combattre toutes les maladies pour que les individus vivent assez longtemps pour procréer.
Cependant à ce que je sache, toutes les espèces ont évolué justement pour mourir,
donc, quand les cellules se divisent, la télomérase devient plus courte et finalement les espèces meurent.
Alors pourquoi l'évolution a-t-elle, semble-t-il sélectionné contre l'immortalité,
quand c'est si avantageux, où l'évolution est-elle simplement incomplète?
AG: Brillant. Merci d'avoir posé une question
à laquelle je peux répondre avec une réponse qui n'est pas controversée.
Je vais vous dire la véritable réponse conventionnelle à votre question,
avec laquelle, en l'occurrence, je suis d'accord.
C'est à dire, non, le vieillissement n'est pas un produit de la sélection;
c'est simplement un produit d'indifférence évolutionnaire.
Autrement dit, nous avons le vieillissement parce qu'il faut vraiment bosser si on veut ne pas l'avoir;
vous avez besoin de plus de voies génétiques, des gènes plus sophistiqués
pour vieillir plus lentement,
et plus vous vivez, plus cela continue d'être vrai.
Alors, dès lors que cela n'a pas d'importance pour l'évolution,
qu'elle s'en fiche que les gènes soient transférés par le fait que les individus
vivent longtemps ou bien qu'ils procréent,
il existe pas mal de variations en ceci,
ce qui explique pourquoi les espèces différentes ont des espérances de vie différentes,
mais c'est pourquoi il n'y a pas d'espèces immortelles.
CA: Les gènes s'en fichent, mais nous non?
AG: C'est ça.
Public: Bonjour. J'ai lu quelque part que durant les 20 dernières années,
l'espérance de vie de pratiquement n'importe qui sur la planète a augmenté de 10 années.
A partir de ça, ça me ferait penser
que je vivrais jusqu'à 120 ans si je n'ai pas d'accidents de moto.
Cela veut-il dire que je suis un de vos candidats pour atteindre 1.000 ans?
AG: Si vous perdez un peu de poids.
(Rires)
Vous vous trompez un peu sur les chiffres.
Les chiffres standards disent que les espérances de vie
ont augmenté d'une ou deux années par décennie.
Alors, ce n'est pas aussi bien que vous pourriez le penser - vous pourriez l'espérer.
Mais j'ai l'intention de faire en sorte que cela devienne un an par an, dès que possible.
Public: On a dit que beaucoup des cellules du cerveau que nous possédons à l'âge adulte
sont déjà présentes dans l'embryon humain,
et que les cellules durent quelque chose comme 80 ans.
S'il se trouve que c'est vrai,
en biologie, est-ce que cela a des implications pour la domaine du rajeunissement?
S'il y a des cellules dans mon corps qui vivent 80 ans,
au lieu de, typiquement, vous savez, quelques mois?
AG: Il y a des implications techniques, certes.
Au fond, ce que nous avons besoin de faire c'est de remplacer les cellules
dans le petit nombre de zones du cerveau qui en perdent à une vitesse assez considérable
surtout des neurones, mais nous ne voulons pas les remplacer
plus rapidement que cela -- ou bien, pas beaucoup plus rapidement de toute façon,
parce que les remplacer trop rapidement dégraderait la fonction cognitive.
Quand j'ai dit avant, qu'il n'y avait pas d'espèces qui ne vieillissent pas,
j'ai un peu trop simplifié.
Il existe des espèces qui ne vieillissent pas -- les hydres par exemple --
mais elles en sont capables parce qu'elles n'ont pas de système nerveux -
et elles n'ont, en fait, pas de tissus qui ont besoin pour leur fonctionnement
de cellules qui vivent très longtemps.